[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle où il est vrai je
suis en 6e année je fréquente le
pavillon saint louis de gonzague
depuis que je suis je poursuivrai mon
parcours scolaire l'an prochain à
l'académie saint louis dans l'option
procure ce sport une île de mes passions
car j'ai le pratique depuis que j'ai
trois ans j'aime beaucoup faire rire mes
collègues de classe mais je suis à être
aussi réguler lorsque ces notes j'ai
choisi de faire en présentation sur un
sujet bref vous voir un étrange
l'épauler ce sujet semble étonnant mais
à la fin de ma présentation ne verrez
plus jamais vous séparez sanitaire la
même manière car vous prendrez
conscience des problèmes d'hygiène
usuelles planète en famille pour vous
oui non mais la réponse pour 2.4
millions de personnes et non pour les
uns des toilettes en porcelaine double
chasse auteurs confort tout est canalisé
évacuer gérer à qui ça c'est notre
réalité à nous et pour d'autres un
simple trou dans la seule mal entretenu
bien souvent les bords elle leur réalité
à eux en ce moment une personne sur dix
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de faire ses
besoins
amplement mal vu serrez vous c'est pour
cela qu'une association nommée l'onu
vise l'accès aux toilettes à tous ces
deux mètres c'est pour cela aussi que
nous avons une journée mondiale vise à
sensibiliser les personnes aux pôles
indigènes à l'échelle planétaire
cette journée a lu tous les temps 9 9
ans
quel est le problème avec les toilettes
le problème numéro 1 est un problème des
vidanges il y as puis de 1.7 milliard de
la ville
bon et 2c 1.7 million d'endroits aménagé
pour que l'être humain puisse soulager
cette éjection corporelle il y en a 200
millions ne sont pas raccordés un
système d'égout c'est à dire 200
millions de la troupe sont vidangés à la
moins ce qui cause des problèmes de
qualité d'eau d'assainissement et
d'hygiène
la solution du japon en observant ce qui
se fait dans le monde japon on ressort
avec sa grande ouverture au pays du
soleil levant
il existe la musique qui vise à
sensibiliser les personnels
un autre matière fécale aussi un
chercheur japonais et par votre minceur
fécales et en fait ça devient même mois
avec une belle sauce geste ray mais eux
semblent plus ouverts d'esprit
savez vous qu'un adulte pour s'emmener
trois ans de sa vie aux toilettes c'est
quand même plusieurs heures et
saviez-vous aussi qu'il y à deux
personnes deux millions de personnes
meurent chaque année de la diarrhée en
315 e mail enfin le québec se situe le
québec un grand projet de
biométhanisation l'idée prêter nos
déchets plus précise et plus précisément
matières organiques résiduelles en faire
une sorte de biogaz le méthane qui est
une source d'énergie
aussi le québec a un programme
d'assainissement des eaux
seulement depuis le début des années 70
enfin je crois qu'en quelque chose je
fais partie de ce grand projet ne serait
ce donc vous sensibiliser à goûter ce
soir sur ce drôle de sujet merci et vous
ne verrez plus vous talent est de la
même manière
[Applaudissements]